Cảc quân nổi tiếng nhất trong sự nghiệp sáng tác của văn cao chính là bay của ca Vinam, Tiến Cun Ca,
được ông sáng tác này sau khi giác mục đánh mạng khi mới hành bú tuổi.
Tiến Cun Ca từ sự đã trở thành bay ca kinh mạng, với ân hồng, thôi thúc,
cầu vốn tinh thần, nhịt thuyết và lòng yêu đứa của bộ đổi nhân dân Việt Nam,
cùng đứng lên đấu tranh dành được lập dân tỏng.
Tại cuốn sân tại hội họp ở tâm trang giữa thẳng tạm nguyện chính trong bú mấy lòng,
các đại biểu đã nhất chỉ trọng tiến Cun Ca là bay hát chính thức của mặt trận Việt Nam.
Sa điệu tiến Cun Ca văn phòng chính bộ trời thủ đô, ngày 19, tạm nếu mùiện chính trong bú mấy lòng,
trong cộng biết tình lớn họp tại quảnh trường nha hát lớn.
Ngày mùa hai tình chính nếu mùiện chính trong bú mấy lòng,
tiến Cun Ca đã được trọng làm quốc cá nước Việt Nam xanh trụ cộng hòa,
và phang lên trong dựa tuyên bôn đập lập.
Và để tháng bộn, mùiện chính trong bú mấy lòng,
tại khi họp đồng tiến Cú có hội phá một,
tiến Cun Ca chính thức trở thành quốc cá Việt Nam.
Còn cộng nghĩ,
giang phải bả ác, mình sẽ thách các bạn mà sau này đã đưa có phùa chọn,
và nó trở thành bảy của ca.
Đi...
Tất nhiêu cái gì ngạc mà...
Chẳng phải bả hát đó,
ông cũng dìm được chắc.
Ví dụ như là...
Đần con Việt Minh thì sao vào phở phở,
rất sống đỏ của yếu không có nổi lần ra.
Thì lúc đó ông chưa hề...
biết là cái lạc ở đó sau vàng của bây.
Ông cũng chưa để bên trên khu.
Ở...
ông chỉ mừng tượng khi giống ra.
Chỉ nên cái hình gạng mà cái lạc ở đó sau vàng sau này nó chạc thành nhận tự.
Đi lạ ông cũng cũng cảm nhạc đặc.
Điều cũng không phải lẫn dựng.
Nhìn thấy để giống tạng tạng.
Bây thích quân ca không nhớ những chỉ là một bản nhạc hay.
Mà nó còn có đầy đủ giá chỉ thư biểu.
Vì nó đã khảm báo tình cảm với nhiều thế hệ, đủ tiếp nhau.
Chạc quán nhiều trận đường rất ngăn.
Và vinh quan của lix sử dân tập Việt Nam.
Ngày bài thích quân ca và hành động từ làm mắc xây hẹn.
Đặc quốc ca pháp, thế nhương,
trong đó con hòa trong đó hòa thơ.
Tôi sĩnh áo ăn rần nữa.
Trong như giống mạc,
tâm hồn, con gầy, giết nằm.
Trong nha xí văn cao toa ra.
Và cho đứng về giờ vẫn sống mạc, cũng về chúng ta.
Nhật sĩ văn cao lúc xin thời đã nói,
tôi viết tính quân ca là thưa yêu cầu của các bạn,
cần một thành khúc cho đổi quân Việt mêng vừa thành lập.
Khi được nhá nước trọt làm quốc ca,
thì nó không còn là cửa tôi nữa,
mà là củ cả sân tập.
Tính quân ca đã thấm đấm vật tình con người đất việt,
vào hồn dân tập,
vào xác tịt nóng xong,
vàng vào xúc chứ dài lịch sửa ngoài hồn của đất nước,
là những tự hào bất tàn của những xân tịt nâm.